this rule in Cabaret is so iconic and
the show is so iconic that I'm curious
have you ever been there is it is based
on a real club the kitat club in Berlin
and you've gone to the real Club have
well it's like it's it's what there is a
club still called the Kit Kat Club in
Berlin it's not like you know it's not a
cabaret club like the one in the show is
or the one that Christopher ISU uh
originally wrote about but it's it's you
know and it's there's still a sort of
decadent layer to Berlin life and I did
go there a couple of years ago and uh
it's just you know they have a very
different attitude to word sex there and
it's I and I like it I think I I
think sh no shame about sex is a good
thing so what is going on in these clubs
I'm just people having it's like a sling
like get in the Dance Floor la la and
then all of a sudden you look over
there's a sling hanging from the roof
and there's someone you know
getting so they have instruments at the
club that enable it's like a a chuck-e
cheese for
adults it's not like a k it's not that
you don't do that have some food and
then I can get on the swing on the swing
but it was a sling not a swing oh oh my
God Granddad come
on it's a SL I still like it in a swing
I don't think it's a kind of That's So
oldfashioned I still have sex in it yeah
you could do and then I actually went
there another
thing the um last time I was there went
there in the beginning this year to kind
of just you know see some things and get
ready for Cabaret and um and this person
was like oh you know do you want to come
to this club it's a really great Club
DJ's great and blah blah and there's
really amazing clubs and things there
and they're all bit intense it's quite
you know and uh they they said there's a
curfew though you have to be in it goes
on till like 6:00 in the morning but you
have to be in by midnight I was like
what and then and then he said I said oh
well I'll see you there about 10: to 12
and he went oh no you have to come
earlier you have to come at least by
11:30 and I said why and they went well
you have to factor in putting all your
clothes in a plastic bag
and I don't think I don't think I'm
P when I hear yeah your clothes have to
go in a bag that's when I say I'm going
to do that like you've got some you know
it's like you going to be sprayed down
with perhaps that might be a good idea
or you might be sprayed down in in a way
yeah but
uh I just didn't I just didn't fancy it
you didn't fancy it no it's not for you
I was having drinks you know I didn't
want to rush it you posted a picture
from your dressing room uh that I have
to ask you about let's here you are
what are you is that you're making what
do you what are you I'm making soup
you're making soup I on Wednesdays so I
make on mattin days I make soup in in a
crock pot for all the cast I'm such an
old granny SL dirty old man and I and
actually what's the terrible lie about
this picture is I didn't actually chop
that my intern Chris
did that is the most shocking thing
about the
photo my eye went right to those
vegetables and I thought
those look intern chop to me he does
them too small actually but never mind I
don't
want you just shamed him in public uh